permitamos utilizar lo que ya sabemos de
la regla de la cadena y la regla del
producto para tomar la derivada de
expresiones más complejas y en esta
ocasión queremos realizar la derivada
respecto de x d
a la coseno de x por el coseno de a a la
x y como podemos ver aquí tenemos un
producto de dos funciones
así que por la regla del producto esto
nos va a decir que va a ser la derivada
respecto de x de la primera expresión
que es que a la coseno de x que va a
estar multiplicada por la segunda
expresión que es el coseno de a la x más
la primera función que es que a la
coseno de x x a la coseno de x por la
derivada de la segunda expresión que en
este caso va a ser por la derivada
respecto de x del coseno de que está
elevado a la x coseno de a a la x y
entonces ahora lo importante es que
necesitamos figurarnos cómo se van a
realizar o se van a resolver estas 2
que tenemos aquí puesto que a como aquí
lo voy a escribir de color blanco esto
es un producto entonces podemos usar la
regla del producto pero a su vez dentro
de cada una de estas expresiones tenemos
que utilizar entonces la regla de la
cadena entonces ahora permíteme copiar y
pegar exactamente aquí para irla
resolviendo de una forma más clara y
bueno entonces como estaba diciendo
anteriormente aquí hay que preocuparnos
por cómo se haría esta derivada y voy a
utilizar la regla de la cadena para
hacer la derivada de iu a la coseno de x
entonces como nosotros sabemos la
derivada de algo cuando está elevada a
alguna potencia viene quedando la misma
expresión pero bueno aquí la voy a poner
de otro color para no crear confusiones
lo voy a poner de un color magenta
entonces esto es que a la coseno de x y
aquí nos queda la misma expresión
a la coseno de x pero aquí lo importante
es que vamos a multiplicar por la
derivada del coseno de x
que en este caso es a lo que está
elevado la ed entonces lo voy a poner de
color azul en la derivada del coseno dx
es el menos seno de xy el seno negativo
de x pero ahora déjenme escribirlo aquí
abajo más claro es la derivada de la
coseno de x pero con respecto al coseno
de x y está azul va a ser la derivada
del coseno de x pero respecto de x y
como veis esto nos queda como un
producto que es exactamente lo que hace
la regla de la cadena justo lo
suficiente entonces ahora voy a hacer lo
mismo con este lado lo voy a copiar y
pegar por acá abajo imaginemos que está
aquí para resolver la derivada respecto
de x del coseno de
a la equis y lo voy a poner de otro
color para que igual se distinga y sea
diferente y de igual forma utilizando la
regla de la cadena esto va a ser la
derivada del coseno de la x que es el
menos seno de ea la x porque es por lo
que está compuesta la función entonces
escribiéndolo de forma más clara esta es
la derivada del coseno de a la x pero
respecto de a a la x bueno ya usado
demasiados colores yo creo que en esta
ocasión voy a utilizar un color verde
para escribir la derivada de lo que
sigue que hay que multiplicar aquí por
la derivada de la x que viene siendo la
misma
a la x y estoy viendo la acá abajo más
claramente es la derivada de a la x con
respecto de x y lo que esencialmente
sigue es tener que sustituir solamente
en las expresiones originales lo que
nosotros encontramos utilizando la regla
de la cadena entonces ahora sólo déjame
copio y pego las expresiones de arriba
para
verlo hacer todo un poquito más limpio o
más bonito por así decirlo entonces lo
voy a poner aquí abajo y esto va a ser
igual a este producto que aparece por
acá que es el coseno de ea la equis y
esta expresión de aquí abajo pero la
podemos reescribir como si hiciéramos el
producto y sacamos el signo del -0 de x
entonces esto va a ser en menos
a la coseno de x por el seno de x porque
ya le sacamos el signo negativo como al
haber hecho el producto y esto a su vez
también se va a multiplicar por el co
seno de la x esto siendo en cuanto al
primer término ahora hay que sumar todo
lo del segundo término pero si te das
cuenta aquí tenemos otra vez una
expresión que como es un producto vamos
a tener un término negativo por lo que
en lugar de ser más vamos a tener aquí
un menor es un signo negativo de toda la
segunda expresión entonces aquí voy a
poner a la x x
a la coseno de xy estas dos en realidad
no importa si las comentamos puesto que
es un producto y no vamos a alterar la
expresión y luego vamos a multiplicar
por el seno de la x que es nuestra
tercera expresión que está conformada
acá y ya no nos afecta como habíamos
comentado su signo negativo puesto que
fue el intercambio que hicimos que son
las que esté señalando aquí arriba a
este producto y finalmente esta es la
expresión que vamos a tener de nuestra
derivada total y ya utilizando la regla
de la cadena y la del producto está
hecho